and here he is a sense of homecoming a
sense of homecoming that is the eighth
sitting United States President stepping
off
that aircraft stepping off Air Force One
a politician that's proud to embrace
Ireland as a fundamental part of his
personal and I guess his political
identity too and it is perhaps these
personal engagements that he will go on
to do this afternoon and into tomorrow
and Friday that best capture what
President Biden himself has described as
the single most defining trait being
Irish and the fact that he hosted the
overradular T-shirt
um earlier this year Well a few weeks
ago at St Patrick's Day in the White
House and
um there was often that statement that's
been said about him it doesn't get more
Irish than President Biden perhaps uh
you know even more so in some ways than
John F Kennedy but here he is greeting
incredibly warmly it has to be said
members of the embassy members of the
Irish government who have been so keenly
awaiting his Iran live when he paused
there at the top of the stairs
making them wait because they have been
waiting for an awfully long time they
have wanted this visit to happen for so
so long